[Music]
the St Louis chess club is celebrating
its 15th year anniversary tell me a
little bit about its impact in the
United States and do you have any
favorite moments uh yeah it's honestly
pretty incredible that it's already been
15 years it just feels like yesterday I
was here but it's I was here 10 years
ago for a tournament the impact has been
amazing for not just us chess but
juniors in the US all these camps they
do for younger players and obviously for
high rated players the US championship
and other high levels so overall it's
just been an incredible club and I'm
hoping for more and better things to
come yeah well St Louis chess club
basically created chess in the US and
there was not really a career for the
most part for any players I mean they
have to travel to Europe to get exposure
and my favorite part in St Louis is
playing the ultimate moves every year
and yeah it's just a tremendous impact
that players like myself self can make a
good living um playing chess it's an
occasion to to celebrate I think all of
us all the chess family really because
what they have done for chess not only
in the US but also in the world I think
yeah there are so many but uh playing
Gary for example uh I think uh it was
2017 the first time I played uh he also
played the rabbit and blit so uh for me
I mean he was my hero from my childhood
and uh I thought I would never really
play him after he retired in 2005 well
my favorite memory were surely winning
the US championship in 2018 but you know
I played that first US championship in
2009 I've been here all 15 years you
know I'm sort of an Oldtimer now there
have been I remember my first US
Championship there's zero other
participants from that tournament that
are here now and you know that's been
the case for a while certainly the
landscape of Chess has changed a lot in
the United States uh and St Louis has
had a lot to do with it well the the
impact is enormous of course I mean it's
not just in the United States but over
the world and it's the most prestigious
Club in in our world at least uh in the
Chess World everybody wants to come to
St Louis you know just to see what's
happening here and to take part in
tournaments because they're always very
nicely organized one of my favorite
memories is um
actually talking with uh Fabiano and uh
Magnus when we had to play tiebreak and
I think um why is it my favorite because
you know mostly you have um players kind
of trying to say that I'm the winner I
want to fight for it and there we just
said okay come on we fix finish on the
same points let's just uh stand there
and pose with the cup three of us so for
me it was very funny yeah it's difficult
to overate the impact that the chess
club has had over us chess and also to a
degree over World Chess in general but
bringing chess to such a high level to
the United States to St Louis um
reaching a level of Chess that we
haven't seen since uh since like the
early part of the century when there was
so many of the best chess players in the
world were from the United States we
have that again and uh for example um in
2016 we were able the US team was able
to bring back a gold from the Olympiad I
think a lot of these achievements for us
chess are really very strongly connected
to St Louis chess club and all the
support that uh Genie and Rex have uh
brought to chess in the United States
and St Louis I've had great memories
with the club from my Years playing at
the US Juniors I played in three us
Juniors and before the St Louis chess
club the US Juniors wasn't nearly as
prestigious as it is today we have like
a field with an average rating over like
2500 these days which was absolutely
Unthinkable even like 5 years ago so
definitely I mean American chess is
really really growing these days the
amount of top players that that play
here on a daily basis is amazing like
just about any great player you can
imagine has come to this club for
example like caspero uh Magnus vishy uh
Fabiano like everyone has played here
it's such an amazing Club one of my
favorite moments is winning the US
junior Championship a couple months back
here and another one could be like right
after I became the youngest
International master I came here I
played I gave a signo here that was
another that was another great memory
favorite memory was definitely I became
a Grandmaster in this club uh I hit 2500
and I mean that's probably one of the
best days in my life so
[Music]
far